my advice if somebody wants to start a
company is
they should bear in mind that the most
likely outcome is is that it's not going
to work
most of the people they have a fancy
ideas in the evening but in the date
when they wake up in the evening or in
the morning they go back to do the same
job
we have a few values that are really
important to us and one
which i talked about before is just
moving fast wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evancar michael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be comfortable with failing with
elon musk
i think failure is bad um i don't think
it's good um
but if if if something's important
enough then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high um
and and so i think my advice if somebody
is
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome
is is that it's not going to work and
they should reconcile themselves to that
past strong possibility um and they
should only do it if they feel that they
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know
um because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's
the very beginning it's kind of fun um
and then
it's really hellish for for a number of
years
you talked about chewing glass yeah
there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur um and uh
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully uh um
he said yeah
the starting company is like eating
glass and staring into the abyss
and you agree with that generally true
um yeah and and if you don't eat the
glass you're not going to be successful
rule number two do it all with oprah
winfrey what inspired me
was um an is continues to be
what continues to inspire me is a
primal and fundamental desire
to the highest expression
of myself as a human being
i don't want to die
not having completely
burned out every single possibility
of my humanity i just i just want to
when i leave this planet i want
everybody did that
used it all up not another thing i could
do there wasn't another person
i could have given of myself to there
wasn't another deed i could have done
there wasn't anything that you just want
you want to say i
want to fill it up you want to take this
whole human existence which when you
think about it godfrey is really pretty
damn miraculous it is it is it is when
you think about what it means to be a
human being
on the planet earth right now that's
pretty awesome
so i just wanna i wanna i wanna take
that to the max
i to say no need to come back as a human
angel status rule number three be
lovable with warren buffett
when you get to my age you will not
measure how well you've done by how much
money you've got i can
guarantee you that you'll all do fine on
money anyway i mean
uh you know think about it seven hours a
day
you know you're in a bed you've got
exactly the same mattress i've got if
you don't listen
to it the furniture mark you know i mean
so so that when we're on a parody i
can't i can't outdo you you know in
terms of my sleeping enjoyment you can
you can match it by by buying this
mattress which we'll give you a special
price on just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a dairy queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat at mcdonald's and burger king and
and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place so our eating
experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a
ten-year-old car up till about a year
ago
you know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it
you know we dress more or less the same
i mean i pay more for my clothes but
they look cheap when i put them on so
we're really on we're on a parody yeah
so
so the money isn't going to be that big
a deal everybody in this country is
going to you know that
with the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean
you know so i won't i don't want i'm not
short changing it i'm just saying you
can't do
too much about that but you will measure
your success in life
by whether by how many and extent
whether it's the people you want at 70
or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end
i mean you can't you know you
you can't buy love i mean it doesn't
work you buy sex you buy testimonial
dinners you can buy your name on
buildings you can do all kinds of things
but the you know the only way you get to
be you know love is to be lovable
it's kind of irritating actually you've
got a lot of money it'd be more fun to
just write out a check for a million
dollars
so everybody you know from now on loves
me but it doesn't work that way
and in fact it the only way is to be is
to be lovable and you know i've got this
friend
who uh who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and what is it now it's uh
60 years later you know she still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself in
determining who she really trusts his
friends
the one question in her mind is would
they hide me
now when you get to be 70 if you've got
a lot of people that would hide you
you've had a successful life i know
people who have a tremendous amount of
money
no one would hide their own kids
wouldn't hide them i mean
they they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know they they don't have anybody's
respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something that sort but they
they nobody loves them and uh
my friend tom murphy at campus cities tv
i mean
dozens of people would hide murph you
know all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know that uh
ben graham a lot of people would i might
my dad would have had a number
and then like i say that i can i can
tell you people
that uh you know everybody may pay
homage to them and
the kids may put up with them and hope
they don't change their will or
something but
the truth is that nobody would hide them
and if you've got a lot of people that
would hide you
when you get to be 70 uh
you will have a very successful life
also if you want to have more self
belief and self confidence
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day
for 254 days the research says it can
take up to 254 days for you to build a
new habit and this program will help you
get it once again it's free
and the link to join is in the
description below to
figure out where your power base is
when i was selling copiers door-to-door
i had a
very clear vision of what my life was
going to be like if i give them a whole
bunch of money and they love the money
and they don't love the business
no matter what they tell me six months
from now they'll be gone rule number
four
keep working backwards with jeff bezos
look
um we would all love all of our numbers
to be smooth
lines up and to the right and that would
be terrific but
that's not how it works you know um you
know the
those numbers are are output
measures and you i mean i guess you
could try to manage your quarterly
earnings
very precisely but i think personally
that would be a mistake you know most of
the work that we put into um any
particular quarter
happened years ago so it's not you know
there's there aren't that many knobs you
can turn during a quarter i mean you can
but they're very they're like eating
your seed corn
if you turn those knobs you don't want
to do that and so
uh it's it's uh i
you know people i think if you focus on
the controllable inputs to your business
instead of the outputs
in the long term you get better results
so the the benjamin graham quote here is
that in the
short term the stock market is a voting
machine in the long term
it's a weighing machine and i think
people are well advised to build a
company that wants to be weighed and not
voted upon
and that means having good return on
invested capital and having
you know lots of free cash flow but if
you said to me if i said
here's a job i would reject if somebody
came up to me and said jeff i want your
job
to be to drive up the amazon stock price
and just manage that directly now this
might sound ridiculous to some of you
but many companies actually do this they
have they actually go out and they try
to sell the stock
that's kind of the final output and it's
much better to say
okay let's not do that that's not going
to be sustainable it's kind of a silly
approach
what are the inputs to a higher stock
price and he said okay well
pre-cash flow and return on invested
capital inputs to a higher stock price
okay
so let's let's let's keep working
backwards what are the inputs to free
cash flow and you keep working backwards
until you get to something that's
controllable
and a controllable input for free cash
that would be something like lower cost
structure
and then you back up from there and you
say okay well you know if we can improve
our
picking efficiency in our fulfillment
centers and reduced defects
defects are very very costly it's
probably you know reducing defects at
the root is one of the best ways to
lower cost structure
and so if you then that starts to be a
job you would accept
you would say if you're you know a
reasonable person you would say i have
no idea how to
uh drive up the stock price i can't
manage that directly it's not a
controllable input
but i i can make your picking algorithms
more efficient
and that will reduce cost structure and
then you know
follow that chain all along the way
that's what you do
in all of these businesses rule number
five take risks with jack ma
when i started my business 1995
it was very difficult i had an idea
i invited the 24 of my friends my
apartment
because that year i went to seattle
first time my first trip to the usa
in seattle i discovered internet and
i think this thing in the future may
change the world
tell me about the encounter with the
internet when you first saw it yeah i
went to the
seattle and a friend of mine he had a
small office with like a four or five
computers
i never touched computer in my life
before because computer was so expensive
to me
and so complicated but my friend said
this is internet just
type in whatever word you want to type
so no no too expensive i don't know
which one to do even now i don't know
how a computer works
like he said jack it's not a bomb just a
typo whatever so the first
word i typed in was a beer b-e-i beer i
don't drink
i don't know why i'm type of beer i
found american beer german beer japanese
beer no china so i typed the word
china there's no information about
china so i say what if we can make some
china information on the internet
let people know about china so that was
the idea
so i came back to china and say i want
to resign
from my school you're a teacher i was a
teacher
i've been teaching in the university for
six years
so i said i want to do it i invite 24 of
my friends to my apartment
after two hours of explaining what i'm
gonna do
internet and 23 of them say forget it
he said this thing never worked because
there's no such thing called
internet in the world you know nothing
about a computer
so why you want to do this and
only one people he said jack
if you want to try it just to try it but
if it's something wrong just come back
and uh after whole night thinking i say
i still want to do it because most of
the people
they have a fancy ideas in the evening
but in the date
when they wake up in the evening or in
the morning they go back to do the same
job
we have to do something different so
from there
i started my business borrowing 2000 us
dollars from my relatives and friends
so that was my trip i call myself
like a blind man riding on the back of
blind tigers
and those people who are expert of
riding horses they all fall down and i'm
still surviving
rule number six find hidden blessings
with sarah blakely
by the time i was 31 i'd lost 11
different people close to me from
separate tragedies
oh my gosh yeah so i've been you know
dropped to my knees many times in life
by grief i mean just
it's like unbearably painful but i will
say that you know going through that i
always
think there's a hidden blessing in
everything that we go through in life
and one of the blessings was that
facing my own mortality at a really
young age
had all these hidden gifts you know
i use mortality and sort of the
insignificance of all of this
in a positive way you know it doesn't
you know
just how temporary this all is to fuel
me and to say why would i ever not do
this
what because i'm afraid that person that
person's not going to remember me five
minutes after i make full of myself
anyway like
let's do this we're all here for just a
short period of time so
it freed me up um in a way that i think
most people in the natural course of
life you know maybe
starts to think about in their 40s when
they might lose a parent or a
grandparent or something so
yeah really how do you get through a
challenging
loss like that like what's your process
oh my gosh i
one day at a time i mean it is just one
day at a time
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is move fast with mark zuckerberg
we have a culture that's very focused on
um being very focused on what we're
building
so focus is a really important part of
it but it wasn't at google for a long
time now it seems to be in vogue so they
may be saying you know this the focus is
better
so but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come
and and add their ideas i mean some of
the best ideas throughout the the
company's evolution
they have just been from just places all
throughout the company whether it's an
engineer
or you know someone on the the customer
support team or just
different uh just different areas around
the company so we've always had
these hackathons right that are
basically time that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's
basically an incubator for people to
prototype different ideas much in the
spirit of how facebook got founded
originally
um the idea that you can build anything
good in a day or a couple of days right
and get a version of that running
um so you get it running you then test
it internally yeah
and then we can see and that that helps
us shape the road map and what we want
to do in the future but
we also have a culture where we want to
stay very focused and
we don't want to run with a lot of
projects that we don't expect to launch
right so so we want to get a lot of
ideas help have those ideas shape where
we want to go
and then execute in a very focused way
on the stuff that we're going to do but
i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us
and one which i talked about before is
just moving fast right the whole company
is really optimized around someone
joining being able to
build something very quickly be able to
launch it quickly iterate very quickly
on that
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and how are you going to take action on
it this week when you schedule in what
day what time and what place you're
going to take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan
and when you share your plan publicly
and have some accountability you
increase your chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
one of the great secrets in life to
becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection
because if you're prepared for a lot of
rejection that comes you don't get
turned off you don't get disappointed
like well i'm not going to do this
anymore no one thinks it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars
they slam them in your face you must be
just as enthusiastic
on door number 101 as door number one
and that's what the real secrets and
growing up as kids in downtown l.a
we all knew that we didn't have a lot we
noticed a lot of things gonna turn you
down
at seven trying to sell a flower pot on
the street most people said no but it's
only 50 cents
no no no sooner a waitress
in a little restaurant said only 50
cents that's really great she bought it
from us
and we went built another one
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below
or if you want even more insight into
how billionaires think check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there